welcome to this video playing brown
brawny Mia what is this guy Bonnie Mia
maxim which I am okay let's see no names
own so what do we get always chance
posing to them samish one of my own in
my own lines now I'm playing the the
total main line here oh I only Nyjah
three hmm the 93 yeah that's tricky it's
one of the trickier lines that i tend to
forget okay that's basically never a
mistake avoiding them the pin down with
Bishop g5 yeah yeah he's got f5 coming
tricky okay let's take the pawn a case
immediately going for that hmm that's
definitely possible came and steak now
now White's threat is f 7 f-6 and I
think I should stop that him mmm I'm not
totally sure about this precise position
one important point is that he has the
night on g3 already sometimes in those
situations where black gets to play f6
himself really wow um he's closing the
pollution in many of those situations
night air force interesting and
that's ambitious
okay of course this chick so let's put
this on the side I have night b7 and
taking this pawn the point is basically
gone so he has sacrificed to pause here
basically
Queen g3 broke g8 okay so that's not
even threatening anything the night only
eight is just covering that okay ook ook
to h3 says attacking IDM yeah well I
mean and this opening is notoriously
tricky so it's not it's not totally
totally simple so night f7 to g5 maybe
to protect a little bit them
and I can take you five more not really
in good shape yeah well I mean it's not
not the end of the world if he if you
would take but still Jim don't really
believe that white has compensation here
what is the the point him I don't see it
I mean the thing is it's difficult to
convert this you have two pawns but even
if white is just putting a rocket III at
Sam it's quite some pressure there on
the pawn so King g8 or something I don't
know Queen h5 I have aged six that's
really nothing happening here
kingi 8h 69 f6 and that's it I think
where is the compensation
avoiding the Queen takes g5 move yeah
now he has to go all the way back on
Queen g6 is just giving away you form so
Queen b7 trying to get the e4 pawn yeah
mmhmm yeah this is not not totally
simple it's two points but it's still
fairly active
training queens would have been on
Slayer then I can play a kid I can
easily protect what is this here Queen
g6 song I mean I can do this right just
to be on the safe side yeah let's do
that and now taking a 3m simply grabbing
more stuff check okay so avoiding this
checking you for him
Jim I don't know just i wonder if i
should go g6 at some point and actually
open open the Queen the King side myself
I don't know
maybe g5 is an idea I don't know don't
think that this is really bad rook g3 I
have Queen f form which seems project
okay I can take with the rook here just
for g2 being attacked the f porn was
always irritating so check I can just do
this right yeah so the Queen trade or do
I have anything better I mean the
Queen's rate is okay nothing wrong with
it okay so look here look f6 the souk g6
then I'm time morning suddenly and
suddenly I'm step by step I mean freeing
up the position here okay blundered that
one check the many many pawns Jeff
really playing us in a pretty stupid
Hessian still quite comfortably wins but
Jeff still could have made my life much
easier check the queenside pawns are too
strong Jeff I simply have too many
points him but it was completely
unnecessary to to do things like that
Chef white for fins on time okay and it
was this the the sameish is always a
tricky opening you you very often as
black you snatch one or two points but
there's still some kind of kind of
counter attack that is dangerous I was
very surprised that he played d5 and
close the position especially
considering that this hive corn is
taking away an important attacking
square from white quite often you want
to swing the rook for example so i have
a hard time to really objectively
believe it and computers as it as it all
quite often is is just totally
discarding this is winning for black but
I wasn't I wasn't entirely sure he could
have taken e5 and I think he should have
done that you know yeah I think I'm step
by step consolidating the pollution
another computer also doesn't doesn't
see any substantial problem with what I
did I'm curious about the g6 situation
if this was okay i mean it's certainly
one of the moves that are possible now
okay the computer doesn't see a problem
with it this is one key point which pins
the rook and essentially
what is the Queen trade I mean by now if
we do a count there I've got seven
points and why does God for point I'm
three pawns up so it's um it's no
problem to return one point and then the
gamer actually have blundered you five
back but it still should be fairly
fairly comfortable fairly comfortable
win okay well thanks for watching